a momentary hitch today for tens of
millions of Facebook users forced to log
in to their normally easy access
accounts what appeared like a minor
inconvenience was for Facebook a major
problem on Tuesday the social media
giant discovered that almost 50 million
of its users were exposed by a security
flaw which Facebook revealed on Friday
meant attackers could have gained
control of the accounts the
vulnerability was in Facebook's view as
feature a security feature that lets
people see what their own profile looks
like to someone else it exposed your
access token the digital key that keeps
you locked into your account without
having to re-enter the password hackers
could then steal that access token to
take over your account
Facebook's reset the account that thinks
were affected fifty million and another
forty million as an added precaution
effectively changing the locks so the
stolen keys no longer work it's also
temporarily turned off view as but the
problems might not stop there
interestingly one of the main comments
coming out is the ripple effect or the
potential ripple effect because your
facebook login can be used to access all
of other platforms so people might be
using it for Instagram tinder those kind
of platforms and as yet there's no
clarity or whether or not those other
platforms might therefore have been
compromised through this particular
breach Facebook traced the hack back to
a change in its video code in July 2017
meaning attackers had access to people's
accounts for over a year
what were the hackers doing Facebook
still isn't sure but it's working with
the FBI to find out and the UK's
national cybersecurity Center is
investigating how the incident affected
UK users the firm said people's privacy
and security is incredibly important and
we're sorry this happened it's why we've
taken immediate action to secure digits
and let users know what happened there's
no need for anyone to change their
passwords the locks have been changed
but the burglars have already been
inside now 50 million users
we'll wait to find out what might have
happened while Facebook was sleeping
Rodman Thorpe Sky News